enjoying us at all  no not at all no  yeah meanwhile the other game between  everyone and Vincent kind of hasn't  changed not not really going going very  far yeah the left for now is just  shuffling also interestingly he is  shuffling in a way that allows G6 G5  which is  frankly a bit of a surprise to me  uh because it's difficult for me to  envisage a situation in which having  squares for the year in Bishop is  not something that we want with black  yeah there we have it yeah there we have  it just resigning there as expected  uh position wasn't really very inviting  anymore  yeah and it's interesting it seems that  discussing a moment around maybe a move  40 where things did change where we  headed into that Queen end game  um  yeah you might miss clearly not happy  with his body language uh about those  variations maybe regretting some  decisions  uh you have Peter what a what